going going through this so you you said
a lot of different things so this is
this has been this has been ingrained
it's in your DNA you've been wired you
felt the fear and the anxiety angst uh
communism creates control creates losing
your freedom creates do you think
America
is as paranoid today you know how they
say only the paranoid survived do you
think America is as paranoid today
as they used to be uh years ago where
they treated enemies in a different way
are we a little bit more cocky loose uh
you know arrogant and you know a little
bit too much of let's share all our
secrets with the world and everything
we're doing and you think you think
we're still in that paranoid mind where
we're worried about the enemy like
before we're a little bit more looser
today
I don't think the United States has ever
been paranoid uh I think the a great and
that that frankly uh is perhaps one of
the things that threatens our our very
existence uh I and I think the thing
that makes the world so dangerous is uh
uh between the Free World and the
totalitarian
dictatorships that we face today there's
a broad Gulf not just in terms of
freedom but in terms of strategic
culture
uh countries like Russia North Korea uh
Iran uh you know China are their
strategic cultures that are are are
paranoid
genuinely paranoid so that they see
threats that don't even exist
and so they're willing to overreact and
over prepare and uh and strike out uh
against threats that are fantasies uh in
their minds we're just the opposite uh
our civilization is what I would call
dysfunctionally optimistic
you know we think that everybody loves
us or we want the rest of the world to
love us we think that the rest of the
world understands that we're not the
aggressors we don't do Pearl Harbor's uh
you know we this this flows from the
nature of the civilizations I should
provide some clarification why is it
that these totalitarian States and
Military dictatorships think this way
and have these perceptions that's
because you know internally
you know the uh political power comes
out of the barrel of a gun for them most
of their leaders have murdered their way
to the top they have constitutions and
laws that are fake uh you know that are
just intended to uh increase the
totalitarian power of the state over
their people
uh it's uh they don't the way they
operate internally is not through
negotiation and compromise and contracts
and the rule of law they operate uh the
way uh criminal gangs operate and uh in
the end uh you know it's the survival of
the fittest it's might makes right uh
there's the uh it's a zero-sum game it's
not a win-win kind of an outcome uh
there's the living and the dead and
that's how it operates within places
like Russia China North Korea and Iran
and so they project their experience in
the domestic hells that they've created
onto the world stage and they figure
everybody else is like that so they um
you know and that's how the world
operates for us it's just the opposite
our domestic society believes in win-win
outcomes we try to negotiate differences
we try to we have contracts in the rule
of law we believe in fair play uh well
and uh and we think the and we think the
rest of the world is like that or and
this is Manifest for example in the
numerous Arms Control treaties that
we've signed with the Soviet Union now
Russia over the years and we never seem
to learn you know they violate every all
every one of them and uh and and we
never seem to learn that for them these
contracts are not binding you know uh
you know that they're willing to cheat
on them uh because they don't believe in
something we have
I guess a manifestation of this thing is
is in our view and in our in our culture
and our civilizational culture We
Believe In This Thing Called Peace for
example there's a condition of peace and
then there's war worse for these other
civilizations there is only War you know
there's war within the society to stay
in power uh you're constantly at war
with the other side even though even
though we call it peace it's really from
their perspective uh the early moves in
the chess game you're moving the pawns
During the period of Peace but you're
really at War and you're getting ready
for the war that's going to come
and uh uh this makes us extremely
vulnerable that is why we are constantly
taken by surprise in the wars that we
end up get engaging in because we fail
to understand that other civilization
one of my jobs at the
see I am when I worked there was to
understand the threat perceptions uh of
the other side what is their military
Doctrine how do they think we could get
into a nuclear war how did they think P
that's not an easy thing to do it's one
of the hardest things to do to stand
outside of your civilization try to put
yourself in the mind of your adversary
and we don't do that well uh uh you know
uh uh and so you've got the worst
possible combination here when it comes
to the
Clash of civilizations you know a
totalitarian civilization that's
extremely paranoid sees threats
everywhere is ready to to strike out uh
and extremely naive dysfunctionally
optimistic thinking uh that we can solve
any problem that nobody sees us as a
threat and that actions that we take
will not be perceived as existential
threats to our adversaries that they
understand we're not going to attack
them it's the deadliest combination you
can have for getting into a World War so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]